we have an update tonight as to how the
pandemic is impacting las vegas strip
properties over the next few weeks we
will be getting updates from gaming
companies
on the very last quarter of 2020. today
las vegas sands releasing its fourth
quarter earnings eight news now reporter
kate houston live in our newsroom
to break down the impact this has had on
las vegas properties
and kate the road to recovery yes that's
right brian the las vegas sands
corporation is
down 2.4 billion dollars in net revenue
compared to the same time in 2019 the
company says
this is due to the monumental financial
impact of the pandemic
the company owns the venetian palazzo
and sands expo center
as well as properties in macau and
singapore although visitation during
the week in las vegas is down sand says
it's doing fairly well on the weekends
the company adds there are some days
that they're almost at 2019 slot levels
although group bookings for this year
have gone down due to continuing
restrictions
las vegas sands is confident in the
demand moving forward
our demand for 22-27 convention is
unbelievable our customers want to come
and we remain very bullish on the return
of las vegas it may take
long we want to it may take at the end
of this year's we see visitations fight
but
please don't be among those people who
have these ideas that you know this
pandemics have put a hole in las vegas
and just the opposite
in addition to conventions and loosening
restrictions
the company says there will need to be
more flights to las vegas
in order to recover and this was the
first earnings call since the passing of
ceo and chairman
sheldon adelson earlier this month the
team says despite the hardship of the
past year
they will move forward with the
creativity and strategy that he was
known for